you
yeah I noticed you boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on super-pumped to be
talking about the computational
properties of consciousness about qualia
about technologies consciousness
technologies super pumped to have andres
gomez and Mickelson joining us on the
show hello hey thank you for having me
this is gonna be really exciting this is
a field that I think we're just now as
primates starting to understand what's
between our ears better and better
and your research and background in here
is actually great it's for those that
don't know Andres is for years as the
co-founder of the quality Research
Institute also four years of writing for
quality of computing also he is a
founder of Stanford's transhumanists
Association and he did his master's in
computational psychology at Stanford as
well as doing a bunch of data science
work over the last couple of years so
this is like the perfect background for
this conversation the computational
properties of consciousness as we get
into that we like to take a big history
perspective on things as we start so a
humans find themselves as stewards of
Earth now we're kind of exponentially
growing in terms of Technology and
population and all this kind of stuff
there may be some stabilization in
population super but the point being
what is your current synthesis on the
state of humanity right well I do have
kind of like a high-level perspective on
what's going on all right so well I call
it kind of like what is like the big
plot of the universe and there's kind of
like I can basically break it down and
kind of like there's a progression of
how like you the more you learned you
kind of like reconfigure the way in
which you think about the big plot plea
big plot and it goes through kind of
like four stages number one is like
battle between good and evil right and
you know like there's you know ancient
people and definitely a lot of archaic
religions believe that right it's kind
of these forces of good force of evil
reality is a playground for them to
battle it out a level above that is kind
of the balance between good and evil and
I think a lot of Eastern religions and a
lot of like new wage and definitely a
lot of you know existentialism may kind
of like acquire that that point of view
I would argue though that believing in
the balance between good and evil is
still some kind of like mood-enhancing
philosophy and it's really a hack to
feel better
like it's not you know like it's it's
it's a if you're believing something to
feel good maybe you're not actually
believing that evil is important for
some kind of balance but but but it's a
widely held view above that you might
have what what you describe as kind of
the gradients of wisdom and and there's
a lot of authors that are kind of there
I would say for example sam Harris might
be there that he describes like whole
like some societies are better for human
flourishing that others and that depends
on like what memes we were like throwing
each other out and like what kind of
technologies we encourage and that's
that's an improvement
it doesn't still allow you to basically
decide between disagreements between
people because they will say like well I
am wiser than you well I am wiser than
you okay how can we use a principled you
know technique to figure out who who is
it and the perspective that that I like
to to basically analyze reality from is
consciousness versus replicators and
that's kind of like but what we've been
seeing you know in evolutionary biology
and and even in in physics and chemistry
that there's kind of like a lot of ways
for patterns to make copies of
themselves and just because a pattern is
really good at making a copy of itself
doesn't mean it's good right it could
actually be really bad in terms of how
the influences the quality of life of
sentient beings and on the other hand
you have the values of consciousness I
mean it so happens that evolution
recruited consciousness for
computational purposes and we found
ourselves here being conscious and
somehow being enslaved to
the desires of other genes programmed by
our genes and our culture but we can get
out of it I mean we can basically
bootstrap our way and obtain freedom
from patterns that just want to make
copies of themselves we don't have to be
enslaved by replicators yeah that's a
good synthesis I like that a lot
yeah cuz you one that there's a couple
things here one of the things is this
objective function that we have to say
okay well certain groups of people
enable maximal flourishing maybe other
people are not so enabling maximal
economic degrees of freedom more meaning
more fulfillment let's say so we have to
objectively function that out and then
this other thing of like replicators is
so interesting like genetics making
copies of itself that things may towards
suffering is not actually good so even
if you're parasitically making copies of
yourself and entering and causing
suffering may not be as good as if we
were to consciously realize that hey now
that we have stewardship of earth maybe
we should turn that valve off for
replicating because that one's causing
parasitic action and turn on a valve
that we haven't explored yet that could
maximize flourishing yeah we have
explored it to a large extent it just
hasn't been put within a framework that
allows it to be sustainable I mean I
would say that a lot of like
philosophies of life and I'm a fan of
for example Jainism and Buddhism very
ancient philosophies they they do care
about the quality of consciousness
intrinsically right is like how to get
rid of suffering but they they don't
have a way of necessarily you know
winning out to battles against
replicators and and that's something
that you really have to grapple with is
like hey this thing these things are
around us and like they're trying to
make copies of themselves yeah yeah now
okay quickly before we go into the words
between the ears what is the deal with
the good and evil of a battle that's
going on on the planet right well I mean
I think that that's that is a framework
that that happens when you have
experience suffering and when your
experience beliefs and you don't
necessarily have the working memory or
the time or the the cultural context to
kind of like sit down and and figure out
like okay what actually mati
the actions of people who cause a lot of
evil when when you examine it very
closely it's not that you know that
people are like literally you know
praising evil itself or like you're
praying to Satan and I mean some people
are but like even them you can explain
away their their actions in terms of
locally pursuing gradients of happiness
like even even the most atrocious acts
that people do in the moment they they
feel like the right thing to do at least
locally either because they they their
world simulation generated by their
brain is basically telling them that
they are the entire world if you believe
that you are the entire world then it
makes sense it's it's almost kind of
like nonsensical to do something good
for something somebody else right is so
evil actions actually make sense within
the restricted domain in which they
happen so I don't think like fundamental
evil really exists or is like you know a
cosmic force out there Oh interesting
so it can potentially be a product of
the environments that were exposed to
for stimuli that help morph our behavior
such as like this weird tumor that can
grow in our reverse cortex or maybe or
wherever and that can cause us to kill
our family we didn't so there's all this
weird stuff in here okay all right let's
let's jump into this where did this
fascination for this three-pound of
organ between the ears where did that
come from for you and then yeah tell us
about that I mean I've always been what
I described hyper philosophical I mean I
obsess over the nature of reality I've
been doing that since I was a little kid
and I mean I would say that my first
approach to try to figure out the
universe was through math and physics
and science but it really wasn't until I
was like 16 that I had very unusual
states of consciousness that it made me
realize that actually the biggest
mystery is consciousness and just how
how poor our models are for that and
also how much potential there is there
was a I kind of like went through a
phase where I basically focused on this
thing that's called like personal
identity which we can get into maybe a
little bit so basically I mean I had
at 16 kind of like a relatively
classical egodeath type experience and
and it was kind of Hindu in the sense of
like feeling that others like these
broader you know universal consciousness
of some sort and but rather than the
typical reaction to that which is you
know kind of like just take taking at
face value of that experience I just
realized okay that's a state of
consciousness and maybe that state of
consciousness is telling us something
useful and and an important but I'm not
gonna believe it just at face value
right so but it did make make me
question things such as like am I the
same person as I was yesterday like is
is the consciousness that will that
these body will generate tomorrow will
be the same subject of experience that I
am right now and technically you've
added which you learned that day to the
mind yeah so then it's technically
different because you added one days of
yeah processing yeah they're the yes and
and the atoms have been changing and
like you know different
neurotransmitters and interesting so
there's kind of three three views here
I'll just sixteen how did you get this
early or 6:15 high I was obsessed with
yeah existential problems and the nature
of reality
this was of like a philosophy side of
things was that the big one I think so
yeah and then what was the ego death
thing if you want to explain what was
the well it was it was I mean I was with
a friend like it I basically felt that I
was some kind of like box and there was
like these energy inside the box and
identified with that energy and then I
realized that energy was outside of me
too
and then I noticed that that energy was
also inside of my friend and then I
realized well there's this point of view
that you can take where you're actually
the energy rather than their individual
boxes and and that was a perspective
change that I mean it really had a lot
to do a thing with my fear of death
which I obsessed over a lot when I was a
kid but but yeah I mean the the lots of
personal identity what one thing that we
like to do is basically provide kind of
like vocabulary
talk about this so I can just say
there's like kind of three big ways of
looking at identity there is closed
individualism there's like the common
sense view that's like you start
existing when you're born you stop
existing when you die and that's it or
maybe you go to heaven you know or you
reincarnate but but you're still just
like one stream right then there's like
empty individualism which a lot of
physicists tend to ascribe to which is
this idea that you're just a moment of
experience and a lot of Buddhists also
think this is like from one moment to
the next you're like completely
different entity they're just actually
you're a different subject of experience
you only exist for one moment in which
case yeah you're a different person than
others but you're also a different
person than who you were a couple
seconds ago and it's a really trippy
view and then there's like a third one
which is open individualism which is
that we are all one consciousness that's
the non localized consciousness not
localized in my flesh vehicle but
everything yeah consciousness yeah
there's ways of pairing up these
philosophies of personal identity with
philosophies of consciousness I mean you
could be a duelist and be open
individual you could also be a pen
psychist and be a Jewess there's I
usually kind of like think of it as like
matrices of like various how different
philosophies interact well but yeah
usually open individually serve pan
psyches they will say like yeah an atom
is also part of the universal
consciousness and which one of those
would you say is the one you most
fine-fine most the best way to
potentially explain I think open
individualism is a really strong
candidate and the second place would be
empty individualism okay I don't give
that much credibility to kind of these
kind of like soul perspective of like
you're just one person and that's it
yeah I find that unlikely yeah yeah and
when you can kind of like tap your do
your like you said you go outside of the
box when you can tap your feeling
outside of the box it can be again it's
very subjective but it can be your
perception outside of the box please
continue us at sixteen with many more
young people to have
these experiences because then it can
catalyze big changes so yeah yeah and
and ideally in philosophically you know
open environments where they you don't
have kind of like just a cultural
environment telling you well you had
this experience and it means this yeah
it's more like hey just you had that
unusual state of consciousness let's
figure out how that P how that fits into
the broader broader whole something I
went through a phase where my objective
was like to change the world by
convincing people of open individualism
so just like writing essays and which I
think like has some merit I mean I think
like when people think of like oh we're
all one consciousness they think of that
as a very non scientific way of looking
at the world but I think like it can be
a very rigorously defined point of view
that it could be an agreed in agreement
with fundamental physics and theories of
consciousness and and there's like a
really strong case for it but um but
later on I realized when I when I went
to college and I started hanging out
with people were into the transhumanist
movement go found it at Stanford chris-
Association and especially I would say
like met David Pierce which is a British
philosopher whose main objective in life
is to eradicate suffering yeah the thing
that that kind of like that made me
realize is that even if you believe that
we were all one consciousness that that
can reduce some aspects of neuroticism
you may you may be less concerned about
how other people think of you you may
also be less concerned about that but if
you have schizophrenia or major
depressive disorder or ADHD or like any
any severe mental problem just that
doesn't help it's not useful right you
actually need to address the actual core
reasons for why the person is feeling
bad which often times are actually just
like physical configurations having to
do with with our brain which is what
actually reoriented my focus is like
okay yeah personal identity you know
scientific accounts for like why
universal consciousness makes sense
okay that's that important that's part
of the vision or also we need to
directly address the problem of
suffering also it's important to note
that when it comes to for example animal
suffering you may convince people to not
you know torture animals you know
factory farming or even like help wild
animals a million chickens per hour in
the US why yes yes yeah it's just the US
right stats are crazy ya know it's it is
upsetting we need clean mean is coming
so thank goodness for Biotechnology and
clean meat indistinguishable yes yes
yeah and animal suffering q yeah yeah
yeah i mean you you will be able to
maybe convene some people to not eat
meat because of open individualism
something like well it is you who is
stuck in the factory farm actually which
is really upsetting to think about very
crazy and yeah but but even up
interesting as in like the atrocity
that's going on and maybe like the
reagan genocide and displacement that
that is actually me yet that is
participating in that as part of this
oneness of consciousness yeah damn that
is some crazy that makes you want to get
rid of that as soon as possible
yeah yeah that's very interesting yeah
yeah because it's not actually an other
that is causing the damage it is you as
one whole entity that is very
interesting yeah because that's the Gaia
hypothesis and even more than pastic
just earth but yeah it may come handy
for the amount of like altruistic
tendencies one has yes yeah now there
will develop there will be cultural
resistance to that and that's where like
pure replicators come into the picture
right is like if you have a particular
psychological mindset that prevents you
from taking in the oneness of
consciousness seriously you may actually
be extra motivated to have you know like
a hundred kids and make clones of
yourself because you don't identify with
a broader whole so
it's I don't necessarily believe that
just memes and you know arguments will
actually win win the battle
unfortunately we need we need stronger
Pacific pacifist and unethical but but
we need likes it stronger mechanisms
which is yes the cheers the audience is
excited which which yeah brings into
relevance like actually exploring the
states of consciousness I mean like
people who are very resistant to
identifying the broader whole if you
show them you know what's out there in
the state space of consciousness and how
indescribably beautiful it can be then
that that can be motivating yes yes yes
that's that that is the sort of
augmentation and perception that can
occur from a meme coming through culture
like a powerful piece of media content
that can get people to really realize
the collective learning that we've
evolved it over the last couple million
years of hundred billion plus people
living and dying to build civilization
that that can awaken people to a certain
extent that's a lot of what we care
about okay but then you go the taking a
step further you're like how can we
computationally understand all of this
so yes so tell us about yeah yeah I mean
computational consciousness is
definitely very interesting the the the
focus is to figure out exactly what
makes an experience positive versus
negative and and the things like you
know we have like this intuitive idea of
like our experiences in terms of their
surveillance surveillance means positive
or negative
I should probably clarify this a little
bit because when I say I want everybody
to be happy some people have like a
pretty negative reaction to that because
they say like well you know I really
love like nostalgia and like if you say
I'm gonna be happy like then I'm not
going
have access to that and or like I really
know I really love like you know
peacefulness and that's like different
than like excitement and happiness you
know but that's why what we care about
is valence which is just whether it's
positively positive or negative and you
can at least in effective psychology
that usually lay out kind of a emotion
in in a in a in a two dimensional space
that has like valence and arousal
arousal is how much energy it has right
so you can have for example low valence
high arousal that would be like anxiety
he's like it feels bad but it's high
energy right and you can also have like
low energy high valens like feelings of
relaxation and serenity so I'm not I'm
not saying interesting how you should
feel happy I'm just hoping that you feel
good like it whether that goodness comes
in the form of relaxation or like a
mystical state or you know like any
super high Pumped energy I don't mind
it's it's up to you like it was like a
well-being or a flourishing well yeah
well being potentially flourishing is a
little bit more complicated because it
also involves having a Greek on growth
on growth as yeah oh yeah that's right
okay but uh mr. Kathuria so Valens was
my became my focus is like hey like huh
how can we figure out what makes an
experience positive and and there's a
lot of attempts to explain these I mean
there's definitely like the
neurotransmitter story right is like oh
so you're toning and dopamine and
norepinephrine or epinephrine even more
so like endogenous opioids which are
probably you know they account for the
bulk of hedonic tone when it comes to
like things mediated by a
neurotransmitters and and that's an
interesting story it's not explanatory
it just kind of like observational it's
like others like this correlation and
it's not particularly great either
it doesn't necessarily tell you how to
improve your state of consciousness and
and and when it's being tried it doesn't
necessarily work especially doesn't work
the long-term
there's like these other stories like
for example externally spera dimes -
something like what you need to be happy
is to have friends and a supporting
family and like a mission and you know
you you've got to be you have activity
there's like the perma model and there's
there's like a whole bunch of paradigms
that are about like what kind of
lifestyle can you have and that's
helpful pragmatically it doesn't get to
the core of the of the question of what
is a good or bad experience because you
could have like major depression and
changing the lifestyle may not help
because there's something else that is
actually causing the problem and then
you have like the the anatomical story
he's like oh the amygdala when it's
activated it you know it generates
states of anxiety or apprehension the
pleasure centers when they're activated
you know they generate beliefs but just
because you call a piece of the brain
the pleasure center it doesn't mean you
understand we're like why why it's
associated with you know valence but
what we are trying to do at the qualia
Research Institute is that actually
providing a formal and predictive
account for what fundamentally is
valence damn ok so now we're talking
like cataloging an experience of what
like a valence of happiness and this is
interesting how you said it's like
irrespective of even like family and
like wealth or basic needs being met
good friends and community and meaning
having a meaningful mission that you're
they are set out to do every single day
because there could still be some sort
of variable that can be tweaked inside
of your mind that can set you on a
depressive course so but although the
things that we mentioned right there can
still be majorly positively influential
as well yeah so what are you guess so
what are you learning about all these
variables cataloging these states yep
we've learned a whole deal of things and
I mean I think like the thing that he's
exciting and how are you doing this is
that through like fMRI and EEG or like
we I mean we've analyzed EEG we've also
I mean something something important to
note as well is trained
who have like trained experienced in
either like because there are long-term
meditators but specifically trained
phenomenologist s-- I mean basically
people who are really good at describing
the subtle aspects of their experience
yeah yeah this is definitely also a
whole topic but I'm interesting
phenomenologist yeah the the thing is
like and this connects also to like
thinking that happiness comes from
external environment but basically
people get obsessed over the semantic
content of their experience basically
what the experience is about and they
don't
and usually neglect the most important
which is the texture of the experience
what does that mean yeah so I I can
provide you a straightforward example so
like consider these three three cases
that a person goes to sleep and dreams
that they see a dragon okay a person
takes DMT and has a weird experience
where they see a dragon a person takes
ketamine and they go to a k-hole and
they see a dragon the three persons come
out and say like what was your
experience about what was it and they
say like oh I saw a great dragon right
he's like that tells me nothing about
the quality of your experience right
like the fact that you experienced that
dragon it could be that you were in any
of a myriad of possible states of
consciousness
what is way more interesting is if you
can describe to me in detail all the the
phenomenal character
of the experience I mean which with
dreams you may have like this resonant
etheric quality and and we could go into
how to describe that on psychedelics it
usually has like excitation inhibition
wave functions and it has like highly
detailed symmetrical patterns and you
know and and this is and so on like
basically what we were interested in is
is actually the fundamental character
which we think is where valence is
encoded okay is this like the examples
could be that I saw a dragon and it
could have been like your little like
pet dragon on like a little table top
and you're petting it playing with it
there's another one where you're like
flying around on a magic carpet around a
dragon that's also a 10 story building
in height and you guys are doing crazy
things so there's like is that what your
you're talking about like getting to
know more of the nuance not even that
because look all of that what's the
texture there yeah what is that
the texture is for example is whether
the Dragons skin felt feathery or
whether it's scaly scaly yeah a feathery
a feathery whether he'd felt rock could
you heat could you feel the heat of the
breath or something like that yeah yeah
okay so and oh oh oh what see what
that's doing it's adding for me it's
it's doing what the memory champions of
the world do they add the other senses
to storing the memory which makes it
more easily recallable so like fur fur
here oh I see so texture is adding the
extra senses to the experience and I can
give you a concrete example that comes
from psychedelics which is I mean I by
the way we don't do research with
psychedelics but something we we do do
is we accept trip reports trip reports
by people who are trained
phenomenologist and like they take
seriously the task of training
explaining their experience yeah yeah
and damn I need to do that mmm I need to
I need a because I write my trip reports
but I don't submit them anywhere and I
need to get better at dexter icing them
yeah and then submitting them yeah it's
pretty cool in quality computing we have
a good a good catalog of like high
quality treatment parts what is a high
quality trip report I mean anything's
like it doesn't get confused by the
intentional content it focuses on the
phenomenal character it describes the
valence it describes the spatial
temporal and auditory frequencies that
are being experienced and tries to put
into math the particular phenomenal
features you know when one example it's
easier if you see it in a picture but
it's like you know one on psychedelics
people look at a texture and it starts
to basically like repeat itself
that's a very common experience
interacting fractal eing and repeating
and tessellation yeah you know that's
been known for ages people have liked
like I think like even Huxley and like
the early psyckadelis East is like okay
yeah the the texture repetition but it
wasn't really only until I think like
2015 I received a trip report by a
mathematician PhD in math who also is a
really good phenomenologist and what he
did was systematically catalog the
symmetry groups that he was experiencing
in this symmetrical textural repetition
and it turns out that when you look at
2d surfaces there's actually only
seventeen possible symmetrical
arrangements of covering the space and
he described that with LSD and 2cb I
believe he could induce any one of the
17 wallpaper groups and like hey okay
now you're putting your hallucinations
into a mathematical framework okay and
telling us something much more useful
okay Oh gotcha yeah yeah so it's um and
then you can cross reference someone
else saying that they had some sort of
they've they've they've tried to
objective eyes a subjective experience
into something related to math which
then can be cross-referenced with other
people's subjective experiences that
have also added some sort of objective
mathematical layers to it interesting
until we can just fully just plug in and
watch what's what is happening yeah
someone okay but now continuous in this
in this exploration of like cataloguing
qualia like I don't even how do you
catalog qualia like where does it go
under what yeah right well there's again
some little bit of vocabulary so there's
like well maybe for the audience we
don't know like what Quilliam quali yes
yes so yes qualia is the the raw
subjective way in which experience feels
as a kid maybe you wondered like is the
blue that I see the same blue that you
see and and I think like a lot of kids
that have worried and their parents are
like don't think about it like like
that's that's impossible to answer right
but it's like no actually I think
there's there's there's ways of actually
telling not not right now but but in the
future that will
ways of actually experimentally
verifying whether we're experiencing the
same quail yeah so in that example like
when you look at a a something that is
blue that is a visual qualia of blue and
you don't know whether other people are
quelea associated with that particular
object is the same and it may actually
is likely that it's slightly different
there's like reasons to believe it's
slightly different and then you have
like what a that would be Aquila of
value is like oh this particular shade
of blue that I'm experiencing then you
have a quickly a variety which is the
state space of possible colors and they
form an actual discrete unit whoa and
you can basically catalog the states
list of possible colors there's many
ways but like kind of like simplest
low-hanging fruit is this concept of at
just just noticeable difference so you
can basically make a two dimensional
rendering of different colors such that
if you look at any two colors that are
one centimeter apart they are just
noticeably different and basically what
that gives you is a ruler by which you
can tell how separate are two arbitrary
colors you can say how many just
noticeable differences makes them
separates them those memes that went
around on the internet the color of the
dress or the work some people think it's
yellow some people think it's blue
whatever you know that's related you
know it that is related that what's
going on there is that they're just out
of the experience the context he is
triggering different qualia values and
and it could be that like when you look
at the Sun or like this when you look at
the sky and you see blue and maybe your
friend also sees blue it could be that
the qualia is the same but they you
still react differently to the dress
illusion because your brain encodes the
context differently in a yes in that
particular case it had to do with
whether you were actually picking up
cues that indicated that a dress was in
closed environment or whether it was
like outside where the particular shade
would actually encode either they were
like blue and there's that there's when
you look at an image you can maybe see a
guy's face or you can see a hand right
or something like that and then if you
look at the black you can see the hand
if you look at the white of the image
you can see the face yeah so it's kind
of like which one do you pick up first
but they're both there so this is this
measuring it's I mean that's not quite
really measuring qualia that's I mean
that has more to do with how your your
brain is processing in Gestalt in
context just starts yeah and it's kind
of like the belt in a sense it is that's
I would say a much higher level effect
that you know it involves like a whole
you know perceptual apparatus aquila at
the qualia blue you could actually just
experience it by directly stimulating
some regions in the visual cortex that
encode for color and or for example like
smells or particular shades like there
were these in sixties experiments where
I can just stimulate a part of my
olfactory part of my brain for smell and
then I can smell something that's not
actually here yeah yeah what yeah yeah
yeah so it's crazy yeah I mean you you
live you live inside a world simulation
generated by your brain you don't ever
have direct access to the external world
rather the stimuli are triggering
queerly of values inside your simulation
that give the illusion that you have
direct access to the world which is
really creepy and not everybody realizes
these yeah so we're kind of taught from
childhood that this is table this is cup
this is water and then those gets stored
as then values kweli of values in my
mind so that when we socialize the
social primates that we identify these
things it can make it easier for us to
communicate and move things in this
physical world but the brain itself is
making a simulation over periods of
years of what this reality looks like
based on these quality
Kweli of values yeah that's quite
interesting so you see you call seeing
something as blue the Kweli is the way
that it effects my simulation yes okay
and then I look at a smell that smell is
the way it affects the Kweli is the way
it effects my actual so is the Kweli of
the actual like the actual kind of like
like neurobiological formulation that's
happening so like when in neurons
you know firing and and more like
strengthening this connection
neurotransmitters occuring that that
process when I see blue that that is the
qualia is making a neurobiological
change that that's what it it depends on
your theory of consciousness yeah I mean
what David Pierce would say is that blue
is actually a particular configuration
of proteins inside neurons I mean like
didn't you think of neurons is kind of
like fairly homogeneous but actually
like so such a big fraction of your
genome is about your brain and there's
so many different types of neurons and
even neurons that are like quote-unquote
the same type like pyramidal cells the
gene expression is different and the
proteins inside them is different so
some theorists suggest that is actually
the shapes of the proteins inside the
neurons that determine whether a neuron
is a blue qualia near on or whether it's
a lavender neuron or whether it's a you
know LA or like a minor neuron I there's
other theories who would say you know it
actually like queerly is happening at a
synaptic level and its resonant patterns
within bundles of neurons and like
inside the nearer and it there's not
much interesting happening we we tend to
actually take a I mean in a kind of like
Foca way of describing would be like pen
psychism where hey actually any given
configuration of matter and energy have
a counterpart in terms of states of
consciousness and there's a lot of
questions that emerge from that such as
like how do you draw the boundary of
like what regions of matter and energy
defined a unified state of consciousness
I mean it's clearly that whatever is
going on in this table is not right
now unified with my experience and your
brain generating an experience that is
not unified with mine but many separate
neurons in my brain are simultaneously
contributed contributing to a unified
experience so there there is also a
mechanism of action it's in the
literature is called the the the
phenomenal binding like how different
states of matter can bind into a unified
state of consciousness and and the the
other very tricky thing about like
realizing that actually you live in a
world simulation by your brain is that
the the valid the mapping between
stimuli and the qualia that you
experience is programmable and the
reason why we know this is because
there's people with synesthesia very
likely yeah they look at the color and
they experience a sound yes and they
could even be like colorblind in the
sense of data they don't experience the
quality of blue they just experience the
sound and in in a sense the the real
answer here is that we are all
synesthetic is just that some types of
synesthesia are more evolutionarily
adaptive and like it so happens that
connecting visual stimuli to visual
qualia and auditory stimuli to auditory
qualia it's a really computationally
effective way of rendering a world
simulation but you know reality could
have turned out differently like if the
history of humanity had been different
it could very well be that we represent
visual stimuli with smells and maybe we
you know emotions with colors and
different arrangement that is also
adaptive yeah okay so we're so we're now
we're taking a real big history
perspective on when single-cell
organisms the multi cell organisms to
actual animals and then the slow process
of evolution where we're seeing the
environment that their neurons interact
with is making a quality qualia imprint
on their on their experience and then
there be refining they're optimizing the
way that they're in that they behave
within their environments
and that's kind of why we see that when
I when I take colors and then I take
them in a certain way I take audio and
touch in certain ways yes yeah exactly
evolution didn't only select four senses
it also selected for sense Quilliam a
piece you've selected for how world
simulations are run inside central
nervous systems sense kweli a mapping
and how how the mapping is are connected
to each other other is inside the world
simulation simulation yeah and I think
interesting if you look at the I mean
there's like a lot of evidence that
world simulations are being generated by
central nervous systems that as humble
as for example a fly or a mosquito like
they do have a little brain yes and
recent research shows that hey yeah they
like there is like an anatomical mapping
such that like configurations of
activity of the nears are actually
mapping what looks like a world
simulation yes I like a hundred neuron
on neuro simulation of what of what
they're doing in their environment why
their move lying this way yeah you know
etc okay we have to because we want this
this is fascinating there's so many ways
to explore this how are we eradicated
suffering through this cataloguing yetee
just about that and teach us about how
we're also maximizing the happiness
states as well right well so quality
Research Institute has kind of like
three big components right it has
philosophy of mind which we talked about
a little bit
there's also niro technology and
principles to guide neuro technology and
then a vision of the future and when it
comes to like the details of how to
eradicate suffering we think it's
through newer technology we we are
interested in like some things like for
example how how to make euphoric
euphoria intent drugs work indefinitely
but that's kind of like a side a side
issue I mention it because he's like
very promising
I think like somebody should definitely
just make an institute for example
figure out how to make heroine work
every time you take it rather than
quickly develop tolerance which is
really important for people who have
chronic pain or major depression and
antidepressants don't work for them
and-and-and there are like fascinating
leads for example there is a problem I'd
and a begain and agmatine that seem to
even reverse tolerance
I call them anti tolerance agents that's
something that the pharmaceutical
industry is not exploring at all which
is anyway but but the the type of newer
technology that we are actively
developing has more to do with directly
trying to increase the neuronal harmony
of your brain which is a kind of like
higher level approach to these one of
the predictions that we are making I
should say you know there's like
hundreds and thousands of books about
consciousness every year you know piles
and piles of paper but how many of them
are actually making precise empirically
testable predictions based on those
theories of consciousness and the answer
is close to none but the qualia Research
Institute actually are theories of
consciousness do generate precise
empirically testable predictions and
that's why we're actually looking to
partner with research labs to be able to
to test these predictions and these
predictions were not only you know
they're not just academically
interesting we're predicting what it
looks like
highly blissful state of consciousness
in terms of brain activity we have like
some precise predictions about if you if
you take MDMA and you're having a really
good MDMA state of consciousness what
that will look like in fMRI not not
exactly just fMRI but also after some
post processing where you can actually
get at what is the what are like the
resonant modes of the brain that are
being activated by the MDMA we predict
is going to be a quote unquote consonant
or harmonic state and the type of neuro
technologies were developing have to do
with basically increasing the harmony of
the brain which connects directly to
valence according to to our
understanding we could be wrong
and the really cool thing is that the
experiment would show it and that we
would move on to other theories you know
there's so many philosophers to just get
completely stuck in a wrong view because
they they don't generate predictions yes
and then you're testing to see then you
kind of have a bunch of of these
empirical tests for qualia that you're
aiming to have different laboratories
and researches so to get funded through
grants and then have those process and
build kind of like a collective learning
base on qualia
mm-hmm yeah I mean assemble a team of
researchers and visiting scholars who
take consciousness seriously which is I
mean surprisingly relatively rare in
academia in my experience at least are
not trying to just explain consciousness
away but rather take take bite the
bullet then hate consciousness is real
and states of consciousness map to to
actual physical states and and try to
map out that's the state space of
possible conscious experiences yeah yeah
that part's also crazy yeah yeah because
then okay because that's how you can
actually see what is suffering on the
state space yes consciousness and
something I was gonna mention is that
intuitively people think of suffering
and happiness it's kind of like a minus
10 to +10 scale mm-hm you're like oh a
bad day is maybe like minus 3 and like
maybe if you take MDMA maybe that's like
a plus 7 or something like that most
likely it's almost logarithmic that
actually the the real way in which you
should be quantifying pleasure and pain
is in terms of like units of pain per
second or units of happiness per second
whoa and there's like some disorders
like cluster headaches that may actually
be in a scale of the traditional skill
of like -10 to +10 it would actually be
like - a million because of how painful
they are it's it's actually kind of like
a power-law where the most painful
experiences are thousands of times more
painful than people even think it's
conceivable but also the most blissful
and beauty
experiences are thousands and thousands
of times more awesome than it could
possibly be yeah yeah yeah well that's
that is super cool because that that
does seem very right is that the worst
experiences you've ever had in your life
or you know shattering a femur or etc
these or horrific ones then the yeah oh
when you're really going deep on the
like 5mb or DMT unity or deep meditate
and profound meditation
those are like tons of times better than
your baseline yeah yeah and these not
only it's not only that the quality is
much better for example five Meo is
reported it's also the amount of
consciousness which sounds crazy to
people but I think it's true I mean you
can modulate how much consciousness you
have oh yeah interesting just this
simple example is like on psychedelics
there's a tip Oh typical case of like
you know you see tracers move your hand
around and you see kind of like copies
of your hand and and there's one way of
interpreting this as kind of like the
garbage disposal of your brain is not
functioning very well so actually
there's like accumulation of quail ear
and in that sense like if your brain if
your experience is usually kind of like
these things lies of a couple seconds
but mostly the last you know 200
milliseconds on psychedelics the the
decay function becomes much more fat so
actually have a lot of accumulated
queerly over a much broader range of
time mm-hmm
and that has more energy it has more
consciousness and something like five
Emillio DMT it's absurd I mean I haven't
tried it myself oh yeah
people who describe it is like oh yeah
DMT it takes you to you know ten ten
times more consciousness 5ml DMT I don't
know maybe a hundred and and it's in
that short a time period of a couple
minutes let's say and then it kind of
tapers down yeah over time so then your
ego kind of realises re-emerged yeah
let's say there's there's too many
places to still take this conversation
will have to do part too soon
what's going on with the with the
technologies for consciousness
seems like we're doing the pushing more
towards spring computer interfaces
there's ways to you know eradicate some
suffering where people potentially can't
use some of their limbs and then we can
add robotic limb and a brain-computer
interface for controlling the limb all
different types of waste to have
technology augment our consciousness
yeah and there's like ethical concerns
in this space obviously this is like a
whole nother episode of conversation
right and I mean synthesis I'm inspired
by the current initiatives that that
exist for brain computer interfaces my I
mean if I if I could not people working
that field would be take valence more
seriously I mean like the there people
are very obsessed about like yeah like
you know be able to you know regain a
limb or someone but hey like research
shows that like if you become a
quadriplegic after you know a couple of
years you're not back to how good it
used to feel but it's not that bad I
mean it's it is bad like it's bad to
lose limbs but relative to for example
like major depression or schizophrenia
that's like a completely different level
and when it comes to like what kind of
uses we might have for like neural
interfaces I would say yeah get rid of
the very intensely unpleasant states as
a priority that would be the that's the
focus I think yeah ethically any morally
serious brain computer interface focus
would be that you're Radek ating as much
suffering as possible with the first
brain computer interfaces yeah that's a
great objective function to focus time
on okay all right okay there seems to be
more and more push towards this fight it
seems like we're rebirthing this sort of
mentality from ancient civilization the
idea of unity of collective
consciousness it seems as though it was
lost a little bit in the last couple
hundred years what are some of these
most important tips or tricks or
principles that we can embody as adults
gratitude practices meditations etc that
can embody this sense of unity more
that is a great question I mean there's
a it's not my specialty I am interested
in like hacking well-being it's not my
specialty in kind of like the
nitty-gritty details of it but there is
kind of this concept of holistic
consistency and you know people freaked
out when in a sense when somebody says
like oh that person is acting in an
inconsistent way or whatnot but I think
like it's more useful to think of it as
kind of a consistency quotient and and I
would have kind of like three areas
basically it's like are your thoughts is
your recognition consistent second are
your emotions consistent or do you have
a lot of mixed feelings and third are
your actions consistent and then are the
consistency also held across these
domains right are your thoughts and
actions consistent are your emotions and
thoughts consistent and an interesting
thing to point out here is that you know
if if you are putting a lot of work in
making your thoughts or emotions
reactions very consistent and the people
around you are not you will eventually
start triggering them and you may even
experience social rejection because they
they they feel bad about like seeing an
example of consistent thought emotion or
action I think there does come a point
in anybody is kind of like developmental
there's a developmental phase in which
they kind of have to let go of cultural
attachments and other you know delusions
that come with with culture and hang out
and basically kind of like
integrate within a status hierarchy
within people who are actually trying to
be more consistent and the thing is like
also you the another problem is like
just over optimizing for any one of
these areas I mean you could have like
hyper consistent thought but a very
mixed and inconsistent emotions and like
that that's also gonna lead to a lot of
misery kind of like that the best
approach is to actually look at which of
these areas are you the worst at and
then trying to improve that that's gonna
what's going to give you the the biggest
bang for the yeah a lot
this reminds me so much of
conscientiousness in general just
setting goals for oneself and staying
accountable towards executing those
goals and and think of like when when a
person notices that there's like
inconsistencies within them usually
there are coping mechanisms the I would
I would highlight kind of like three big
company coping mechanism one of them is
ego fragmentation quote-unquote being
hypocritical or having double standards
second would be neuroticism or basically
you you experience an inconsistency
within you and you project it into the
world and you think no is like the world
that's messed up
so you become angry or helpless people
who are very helpless usually you're
projecting a lot of their
inconsistencies and third reducing your
working memory so for example strategy
is like drinking alcohol watching sports
and fanaticism and being obsessed with
politics all of these things like
saturate your your mind so that you
don't actually realize and though there
are inconsistencies there so I would
generally avoid crowds that use heavily
any one of those coping mechanisms damn
that's a there's a really strong piece
of wisdom that I don't think we got it
we got to be really good at looking
ourselves in the mirror and and
challenging ourselves to change some of
the patterns that we want to grow and
and help us maximize our own potential
okay
just couple power round thoughts on the
way-out core driving principle of your
life I mean honestly the highest one
would be reduced as much suffering as
possible I love it
yep you know are we in a simulation yes
okay well if you were talking about like
are you perceiving the world directly
the answer is no you experience a world
simulation by your brain there's this
other bigger question like is the
universal simulation and and we do have
some thought on that I can quickly
describe it please so it comes down to
intent like why would anybody build
these universe as a simulation and I
think there's like two possible clusters
of reasons number one is that it serves
and
extrinsic purpose like for example
computation like hey like these
hyperbolic high dimensional aliens are
using our universe to run their TurboTax
or whatever you know just is very
computationally efficient right so they
just do it and we are a side effect of
that or maybe like AA stocking and
figuring out the universe like maybe
that is like computationally effect
efficient for whatever reason they're
like extrinsic extrinsic purpose and
then the other possibilities that the
universe is being built for its own sake
in which case you may ask
okay so along what axis would the
universe be optimized for if you're like
us in quelea Research Institute that you
think that value is like a you know a
real fundamental axis in the universe
and quantifiable then questions like is
a black hole experiencing bliss now that
becomes relevant it was the big bang a
massive moment of please or was it like
neutral experience and how about like
quantum foam or the far future and but
we would claim is that if you if you
have a mathematical theory of valence
that can take physical systems and tell
you is this suffering is these like in a
state of bliss and we apply that theory
to quasars and black holes and Big Bang
and it comes out that all of them are
like extraordinarily happy that would be
evidence that these universe is a
simulation for an intrinsic value that
namely these are like heaven worlds and
maybe us humans and biological suffering
is just a rounding error like we were
insignificant relative to like what's
actually going on in these like
cosmological interest states scales yeah
yeah that's cool
okay and the last question is what's the
most beautiful thing in the world
I think I mean objectively it would
probably be some super optimized the
state of consciousness there's most
similar within humans might be something
like the combination of MDMA 2cb and
ketamine potentially based on some
reports but I think like our
aesthetically I would say the fact that
you can combine intelligence and
happiness that they are not mutually
exclusive I think that's beautiful
okay what an answer yeah yeah do it give
me just another quick bit intelligence
and happiness they're not mutually
exclusive give me that a lot of people
think they're not I mean there's like
these meme of like are you gonna take
the blue peel and have a happy life but
being ignorant are you gonna take the
red pill and face reality like well if
you know valence is like an actual
physical property of the brain and and
you can recruit valence in order to
represent semantically accurate world
simulations then you can have like hyper
blissful hyper lucid the states of
consciousness and in a sense like a lot
of neurotic people when they take MDMA
for example they become way happier and
way more reasonable they're actually
able to objectively assess situations
much better so is the the trade-off
between are you want intelligence or
happiness is is a vacant economy yeah
yeah the purple pill the purple pill yes
I love it I love it this has been super
enlightening I think we've learned a lot
about the computational properties of
consciousness through this episode we
greatly appreciate you coming in the
show thank you so much thank you very
much I really appreciate your work it's
it's amazing thank you so much thank you
I really appreciate that and we think
the same thing about your work is we'll
also keep up the good work
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we would love
to hear from you in the comments below
about some of these things that we were
talking about go and start exploring
what this all looks like computational
cost
interesting stuff go and check out the
links below to Andres is work all that's
below support people like Andres like
the qualia research institutes like
qualia computing also like simulations
support your artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in most support them
thanks to Ron for producing and
directing the show thanks to you guys
for tuning in we love you so much
and build the future build it we love
you